imposter syndrome is the feeling of
being a fraud of
being unprepared why did they pick me
who am i to show up and do this
more and more people would come up to me
and say how do i get rid of this and
they're surprised at my answer which is
not only can't you get rid of it you
shouldn't want to
because it's the sign that you're
healthy it's a sign you're doing good
work
because if you're trying to invent the
future of course you're an imposter
because you haven't seen the future yet
it's not here you are acting as if
you're putting something into the world
that you cannot be as qualified to be as
someone who's a street sweeper because
the street sweepers swept that street
yesterday they know they can do it
there's no imposter going on at all but
if you're
imagining that people are going to be
moved or changed or influenced by what
you're about to do
but you've never done it you're an
imposter so when it shows up the answer
is thank you thanks for letting me know
i'm onto something here i
am doing this work and feeling it the
same way
you run a marathon you better get tired
because if you don't get tired
you're not trying hard enough
what is the practice well the only two
kinds of successful people in the world
um what they have in common is that
they've solved interesting problems
that they've shown up and made something
better that they did something original
something
important maybe they did it by waiting
for the muse
to touch them by getting picked by
somehow getting permission
but more likely in my experience of
talking to
lots of people from every line of work
is that they have a practice
that they show up on the regular that
they have a way to see
for a word to produce this work even
when they don't feel like it especially
when they don't
and so i wrote a book about this process
of shipping creative work
and it counters so many of the myths
that people have
about what does it mean to even be
creative what does it mean
to do this work you're proud of what are
the biggest misconceptions
or the things that most people get wrong
about creativity
well they think that you need to be in
the mood that
it happens when you find flow that
uh all criticism is the same that
writer's block is real
that the muse can be summoned
a whole bunch of things that put it
outside of you
that turn it into some sort of gift or
talent
no one talks that way about plumbing no
one talks that way
about most of the things in our life why
do we talk that way about this
important thing and it's because we're
afraid yeah i
recently had your friend steven
pressfield on the show and i see a lot
of parallels between the practice and
the war of art and turning pro
is that were you influenced by him when
writing this book
i don't think it's fair to call them
parallels i think it's fair to say i'm
stealing from him
um i was trying to be so diplomatic
seth steve steve is a dear friend
um and he and i differ about a couple
things
he actually uh
is more spiritual about where does this
stuff come from
but what i tried to do was share my
personal experience
you know i discovered the war of art 10
years ago when i was writing linchpin i
can't believe no one told me about it
beforehand
and what i believe is that we are not
involved in an epic battle against
resistance i believe we are dancing
with feelings that exist to protect us
and you can't win the battle but you can
learn to dance with them
it's a really lovely way to frame it i i
have to say of the stuff that stephen
puts forward the
more esoteric kind of um
metaphysical stuff that's there is for
me as someone who's quite
salt of the earth is a little bit more
challenging but by hook or by crook i
think the outcome is correct
and i definitely see the the
similarities i love
the way that there's certain aphorisms
and maxims
in the practice that are really they
sort of spearhead
a big big chunk of work and they they
kind of drive it home
so let's define our terms before we can
do anything we have to define our terms
how do you define creativity what is it
to you
so creativity is not painting
or writing an opera it's simply solving
an interesting problem
in a generous way that might not work in
a way that only a human can do it
so there are elephants who can paint oil
paintings but they're not
they're not being creative and there's
that famous
uh selfie that a macaque uh monkey took
in indonesia it's not a selfie it's not
a selfie
because the monkey didn't know to be
nervous when it pointed the camera at
itself
and so you've got to have this human
element for it to meet my definition of
creative
yeah you say that creativity is an
action not a feeling
and that you put a lot of emphasis on to
people
showing up and doing the work you use as
a good example yourself that
you don't blog because you have to blog
you blog because it's tomorrow
and each day another piece of art
another article comes out
one question i have there is how do you
not kill your love
for a topic or a creative output by
brute forcing your work rate
well i am in favor of hobbies totally in
favor of hobbies
but don't try to sell them to people do
your hobby because you love it
do your work because it's your work now
it is possible
to learn to love your work you can learn
to love being
a plumber you can learn to love being
someone who paves roads in a steamroller
right that i don't think that we should
try to find
our passion i think we should be
passionate about what we do
because it's way easier to end up happy
if you can make that decision
so at the beginning writing a blog post
every day
felt like a lot and if someone had said
now you need to do it 7
000 times in a row i probably would have
pushed back
but like everything that humans deal
with we get used to it
if your job had been 15 years ago to sit
in front of a tiny screen
and spend two to three hours
doom-scrolling your way through the
state of the world for money
people would have had a nervous
breakdown they would have killed
themselves now people do it voluntarily
and so the thing is you can seek
to do the work for good reasons and then
you can fall in love with the work
you don't have to worry about killing
your joy if you choose
to find joy i really like that i think
that's a
lovely distinction one of the examples
that i loved one of my most favorite
examples is about you
teaching people to juggle can you
explain what learning to juggle has to
do
with our process and a desire for an
outcome
so i've uh taught thousands of people
how to juggle i'm not a great juggler
but i know how to teach it
and because they're not related being a
good juggler and being a
juggling teacher when i ask people if
they want to learn how to juggle
they say oh sure and they grab three
balls and they start throwing them
and inevitably what happens is people
have seen jugglers before and what they
pay attention to when they see a juggler
is the catching juggling is mostly about
catching
that we root for the person if we're on
their side to not drop a ball and if
they do we go oh
and so as soon as you start learning how
to juggle
within two or three throws not you
because you're an extraordinary athlete
but in general
you lunge for a ball it's out of place
you lunge to catch it because catching
is what you're supposed to do
well once you've lunged to one side now
you're way out of position for the next
one
and then the balls are going to drop and
you're going to fail and you're going to
say i hate juggling
and you're done and that's why almost
nobody knows how to juggle
so what i do is i say this is going to
take about an hour
and it will not take less than that so
here we go we're going to spend 20
minutes
throwing one ball and not trying to
catch it
throw throw throw throw it drops on the
ground we pick it up
and then we're going to do it with the
other ball throw throw drop drop
so half an hour into it we've done throw
throw drop drop
over and over and over again which means
that you are now really good at throwing
and if you're good at throwing
the catching takes care of itself
and we live in a culture that rewards
people who lunge
that rewards the emergency save
but that's a mistake what we need to do
is reward the throwing
and not worry about catching get the
throwing under control if you learn
the practice you'll be amazed at how
easy it is to catch
i love that it's one of my two favorite
quotes first one our work is about
throwing
the catching take takes care of itself
the second one
process saves us from the poverty of our
intentions from elizabeth king
like that unfulfilled life you know they
say that true hell is when the person
that you are meets the person who you
could have been
and that process saves us
from the poverty of our intentions wow
that is i love that
um the the hack trap take us through the
the trap of becoming a hack the race to
the bottom tell us about that
well i want to do elizabeth king for
just one more minute because i wouldn't
have been able to do the book without
having
uh stumbled upon her and her work
watched the documentary and now
proud to call her my friend um what does
it mean the poverty of our intentions
well let's go back to this whole idea of
a workout if you negotiate with yourself
at mile one of a run you will never run
nine miles
that is the worst time to decide how far
you're gonna run
you should have the discussion at the
best part of your day
tomorrow i'm gonna run nine miles now
you've made the decision when your
intentions show up later and
you are negotiating for it to be less
that's not
the moment when you're going to make art
and so what the practice says what the
process is about is
i'm not going to decide that i'm not
going to have a blog post tomorrow i
made that decision 20 years ago there's
going to be a blog post tomorrow
so now that decision is made it doesn't
matter what my intentions are
there's going to be a blog post tomorrow
and
that feels fairly draconian
but what it does for me
is it lightens my cognitive load
enormously
i don't have to have a meeting with
myself about this i also don't have to
have a meeting about being a vegetarian
or watching television i made these
decisions a really long time ago
and so then i can go back to work right
that's
that ties in really nicely with a few
things i've been thinking about recently
i'm a big advocate of sobriety for
productivity use i think it gives you
more time more money and more calories
to spend on things that you care about
but my background is a club promoter
so i've run nightclubs for 14 years um
so there's a little bit of a
juxtaposition there but i made a
commitment to myself and anyone who asks
and anyone who's listening to this go
back and
just search modern wisdom sobriety it'll
pop up wherever you're listening um
what i tell everyone who wants to go
sober who says i want some of those
gains
is pick an amount of time you're going
to do it for
don't have an open-ended window
28 days three months six months one year
whatever it might be i'm 26 months into
this particular stint of it for myself
um for precisely that reason it doesn't
give you the opportunity
it lightens the cognitive load whether
you believe in ego depletion and
the the um sort of desecration of
willpower throughout the day there's
some
interesting stories about ceos in
silicon valley always wearing the same
clothes
because it means they don't have to make
that decision they can save that
decision-making
for the decisions that matter yeah
yeah that's great uh just an aside we
have a friend who wrote
an important book about the history of
drunk driving because if you think about
it it has to have a history because
first you had to have driving right
and uh we did a book party for him
and we decided we couldn't have a bar
because it was a
book about drunk driving and i got to
tell you
as someone who has never consumed
alcohol just by choice
it was a terrible party people
people just did not know what to do
and we had one friend who showed up and
she had uh severely sprained her ankle
and her husband's a doctor and she had a
note from her doctor that she was
allowed to drink
for medical reasons but everybody else
like so as a club promoter i'm just
telling you you might want to not
make this a widespread thing but i
totally agree with you about it
my parties are going to suck let's start
getting everyone to be
to be sober oh man yeah i can i can
imagine that look right
hack trap take us through the the trap
of becoming a hack
so um you're not from around here are
you in london or near london right now
newcastle winterfell of uh okay okay
okay so there's coal there but there's
no hack
uh there is a borough of london called
hackney
and it used to be on the outskirts when
london was smaller and they raised
horses there
but they didn't raise racehorses or show
horses or jumpers
they raised ordinary cheap horses if you
needed
if you need a horse here's a horse well
what kind of person buys
a horse it's just a horse a reliable
cheap horse
that you want the answer is a cab driver
and that's why london cab drivers are
called hacks
because they got their horses from
hackney and
that word then evolved to mean
whatever it's it's what you asked for
we're done
even stephen we don't know each other
anything there's no excellence involved
here i don't think there's anything
wrong with being a hack
unless you also want to be an artist at
the same time
so what it means to be a hack is give
people exactly what they want if you
look at television
television is filled by tv shows made by
hacks right
there's a network that says i want to
show like this
play to the lowest common denominator
here's the budget it gets done
it doesn't matter that most of the fast
food is
made by hack that there was a day when
fish and chips in england was special
and now it's just
a hack food made for people who are just
trying to get some calories
but there's a different kind of work and
it is the work of
leadership of saying to the people who
think they want
something that's pretty good to say
actually
consider what would happen if something
extraordinary was on
offer it's not for everyone and it might
cost more in time and money
but for some people this this matters
and that work is not the work of a hack
it's the work either
of a amateur who's doing it for love or
a professional
who's engaging in a contract with
someone saying yeah
you're hiring me because i'm a
professional i'm going to change the
game for you we're going to take it to a
new level
but don't ask me to do hack work because
hack works easy for me to get but i
don't want to do that
i want to do work that will challenge me
to solve interesting problems
and so in the book i try to outline for
people
you can need do either but don't be
confused
don't be a hack and pretend you're an
artist and don't be an artist
and act like a hack i read last night
the toxoplasma of rage by scott
alexander have you read this
i haven't i know about toxoplasma and i
know about scott alexander but i missed
the connection so go ahead tell me
it's an unbelievable blog post widely
cited as
the most important blog post on slate
star codex
um so anyone who is interested that's a
big that's a very big shout out i know
he's a prolific
him and elliott yudkowski and two people
that probably
would compete with you for volume of
blog posts written over the last couple
of decades
uh and basically he talks about
precisely this
that the stories which are the ones
which are most newsworthy
are the ones that cause the most vitriol
and
um debate from either side which
inevitably
reduces their effectiveness so peter as
an animal change organization
garners more support from the press
because it does stuff that
is outrageous but by its very nature it
polarizes people
as opposed to and he gives some examples
i can't remember of
more conservative sedate chilled animal
change organizations
who don't get the easy wins in terms of
exposure
but do get higher conversions of those
people that they reach
and i think like ready last night like
just stumbled upon it decided to read it
last night yeah appears
completely in line with what we're
talking about here yeah i know scott's
extraordinary and
uh i highlight one of his posts in the
book
uh we've met just once but he fell out
of my blog reader because of the whole
fight he had with the new york times so
i got to put him back in because
otherwise i would have read that already
so toxoplasma we need to talk about that
even though it's off topic
toxoplasma is a real thing it is a
disease organism that afflicts
rats and what it does is it makes
rats attracted to the smell of cat urine
because this microorganism that lives in
the brain
of a rat cannot procreate
unless it gets eaten by a cat so it
takes
over the rat causes it to die
so that it can reproduce and i've been
working on something about the media so
now i gotta go read this because it's
totally related which is
we believe that
we see the world as it is but we live in
culture
and culture changes what we see and
culture is driven
by media and media is driven by a
business model
what's happened in the last 20 years is
the business model of media has
dramatically shifted
and it has decided
that it profits the most when we are on
edge
insecure and feeling insufficient so
even though as we see
from steve pinker's great book the world
is safer and healthier than it has ever
been before
even counting covid no one thinks that's
true
and the reason people don't think that's
true is because the media doesn't want
us to think it's true because it sells
papers
in quotation marks so yeah it's
interesting to to make the analogy to
toxoplasma it's just so fun to talk
about toxoplasma
but he is correct that the way we change
the culture
is not by getting a trending headline in
social media
we change the culture by establishing
that people like us do things like this
and persistently and consistently
chipping away at the edges
i got to give you you ready to rant
about that oh absolutely toxoplasma
gondii has appeared in two newsletters
as well and i only started it halfway
through this year so we're all we this
is the toxoplasma fanboy podcast
right now me and seth here party of two
um i gotta give you another another
thing
uh that i've recently come across from
stuart russell's
human compatible which is about the
control problem for artificial general
intelligence
very similar to super intelligence by
nick bostrom or the precipice
by toby ord if you're into existential
risk and one of the things that he
brings up there
is that the optimization algorithms on
social media feeds like youtube and
twitter and facebook
not only are they trying to uh produce
content that you are
most likely to click on it wants you to
click on the things there the easiest
way
for the social media algorithm to do
that is to make your preferences
more predictable and people who are out
at the extremes and are polarized
are much easier to predict what they're
going to click on someone who's centrist
and has a nuanced view
will tip one way then on the next thing
they'll tip the other way
and again with that like i know we can
tumble down the uh malicious
techno sort of critic world that we're
in at the moment as hard as we want
but the point is that there are a number
of different forces at play here
both conscious and unconscious both
automated
and creative that are all kind of racing
to the bottom
and i think that i think that what you
talk about there i know it's not
necessarily the single
important outcome but all of this
highlights that if you go
towards something which is a creativity
which is virtuous and you speaking your
sort of highest
form of art forward that's a competitive
advantage because it's a game that very
few people are playing
correct it's a game that most people
don't even think they should or are
allowed to be playing
and you know kevin kelly's book what
technology wants
is a must read it will change the way
you see
so many of these issues kevin's the
founding editor of wired magazine
he is a sage this is his best book
and basically he argues that technology
is a species
and it is evolving and forcing us to
change as it does
and if we figure out what technology
wants we start to understand things
and i was assigned to an executive who
had worked both at facebook and twitter
and watching how facile he was at
justifying
all of the bad decisions that they make
because
nobody there in my experience is
particularly evil
but everyone there is doing in the short
run what they feel like
they're supposed to do as opposed to
taking a
step back and saying yeah that might
work but what would i be
proud of and that is inherent in
art art when you're not being a hack
has to be something you can point to and
saying i made that and the number of
people
who work at facebook were saying yeah i
invented it so it would end up like that
not very many people are saying it
because they don't want to own it
they're hacks
i think the guy who co-created
the infinite scroll says that it was the
single
worst invention he's ever made in his
life his single biggest regret of his
life
oh my god it was terrifying
uh okay so how do we deal with criticism
you talk about criticism in the book
as someone whose platform is growing now
this is something that personally for me
is a
a really important thing i'm starting to
garner sufficient traffic that
criticism comes thick and fast how can i
deal with it
yeah so old dad joke guy goes to the
doctor and
uh said the doctor says uh you got
trouble your heart's going to
give out in a few weeks he says i want a
second opinion
and the doctor says okay you're ugly too
and
the thing is i would value the doctor's
opinion on the first thing
but on the second none of his business
none of his business
because you're in a relationship with
someone who doesn't think you're ugly
the fact that the doctor thinks you're
ugly is irrelevant
so the key here is that
all criticism is not the same just
because someone
found two earbuds and listened to your
podcast doesn't mean you care about
their opinion
it may very well be that they should
listen to somebody else's podcast
you're not trying to be joe rogan so if
they want to listen to joe rogan they
should go over there
if they start saying you need to do
these things to be more like joe rogan
so i'll like you you need to say
joe rogan's over there and that
was a huge lesson for me to figure out
who are we seeking to serve where is the
smallest viable audience and how do i
ignore
everyone else so 15 years ago i took
comments off my blog and there was an
outcry this is not a real blog there's
no comments don't you care blah blah
i realized if i left the comments on
i was going to write every blog post a
little bit longer explaining myself a
little bit more
trying to get rid of any place for
someone to criticize me
and eventually i'd have no blog so i had
a choice blog with no comments
or no blog and i got rid of the comments
and 10 years ago
i stopped reading the reviews on amazon
haven't read one ever since
and my writing has gotten better not
worse
because a one star review doesn't tell
me i did a bad job
it tells me the wrong person read my
book
i love that i also think that it ties in
a lot with
enacting whatever you feel is true to
yourself in creativity
because if it's something that is
genuinely
unmolested from what you want to do to
its creation
you don't second guess it i think
criticism
probably strikes at people who are
playing this metagame or perhaps being a
hack or
20 hack 50 hack whatever particularly
harshly
yes now there's something that goes with
this that's super important
which is just because it's what you
wanted to do
doesn't mean it's guaranteed to work
those are two separate things
right so if you want to compose a
symphony that's played
entirely on raw pieces of fish please do
but do not expect the commission from
the london symphony orchestra they're
different
things and so part of what we do as a
creator is we
we've got to figure out who do we seek
to change what change do we seek to make
and then we have to make it for those
people
those people are the ones who are
seeking to change not necessarily
ourselves if it's a hobby that's
different
but if it's professional work you're not
allowed to hate your customer you're not
allowed to hate
your fan because you're there for them
just as much as you need them to be
there for you
do you advocate a formalized process
before people they explore before you
exploit
sit down work out your core values
trying to think about what the project
means to you
and avatars of perfect audience members
and stuff like that
is there a way that people can kind of
synthesize this into something more
real yeah we talk about this uh i talk
about this and this is marketing and we
cover it in the marketing workshop
so i believe that intentional action
sometimes called design thinking
saves a lot of time and energy who's it
for
what's it for what do i seek to
accomplish these three questions how
will i know if it's working
you don't have to answer those questions
but then you're stumbling around in the
blind
in the dark trying to knock a pinata out
this is different
this is saying i'm here on purpose with
an intent with a reason
that's hard because it puts you on the
hook
and people don't want to be on the hook
because if you announce it
and it doesn't happen then you got to
say i failed
i could do better it didn't work whereas
if you don't announce
it there's a lot more wiggle room and
so bob dylan who makes up stuff even in
his own autobiography
tells the story of what happened after
he went electric at newport
and what he did was uh he had a very
specific idea
about the music he wanted to make who he
wanted to make it for
and what change it would make and he had
a problem which is his fans didn't want
him to do that
so in that moment you decide do i want
to be a hack
or do i want to make art and so he said
to his
promoter here's the deal we're going to
go to all these cities
three years in a row every year we're
going to go to the same towns
and the promoter said that doesn't make
any sense you got to give the town time
to cool out he said no here's why i want
to do it
the first year we're going to show up in
st louis or denver wherever
and we're going to get booed and the
second year those people mostly won't
come back
and the third year the people who like
me will bring their friends
and it took three years to clean out the
audience
but by doing that he could get back to
making the music he wanted to make for
people who wanted to hear it
but first he had to be specific in mind
not i'm going to change the mind of
people who want the old stuff
but to say i'm going to bring in a whole
circle of people
who want the new stuff i did a lot of
research before i started my newsletter
this year
and one of the little maxims that i came
across there which i really loved was
never fear the unsubscribe yeah
and i think that that's precisely the
same you actually want as many
unsubscribes as possible you want to
prune that audience down
and this leads us nicely into something
i get a lot of messages about
imposter syndrome which is a hell of a
drug um
how can we get past imposter syndrome
and that's the perfect way to ask the
question so for the 12 people who have
not experienced it i will explain that
imposter syndrome
is the feeling of being a fraud of being
unprepared
why did they pick me who am i to show up
and do this
and as soon as it started getting talked
about more and more people would come up
to me
now that they could talk about it and
say how do i get rid of this
and they're surprised at my answer which
is not only can't
you get rid of it you shouldn't want to
because
it's the sign that you're healthy it's a
sign you're doing good work
because if you're trying to invent the
future of course you're an imposter
because you haven't seen the future yet
it's not here you are acting as if
you're putting something into the world
that you cannot be as qualified to be
as someone who's a street sweeper
because the street sweepers
sweep swept that street yesterday they
know they can do it there's no imposter
going on at all
but if you're imagining that people are
going to be moved or changed or
influenced by what you're about to do
but you've never done it you're an
imposter
so when it shows up the answer is thank
you
thanks for letting me know i'm onto
something thanks for letting me know i'm
not mentally ill
here i am doing this work and feeling it
the same way if you run a marathon you
better get tired because if you don't
get tired
you're not trying hard enough i think
that ties back
to what we were saying before about this
kind of i guess the compromising
of how far you're pushing the boundaries
the
competence your domain of competence
right that
a lot of people perhaps might feel that
imposter syndrome
which gives them a sense of a lack of
confidence and then compromise by
copying what someone else does
so their imposter syndrome gets down
regulated
because they know maybe i haven't made
this work
but if i do precisely the same thing as
joe rogan or scott alexander
or whatever whatever like my hero within
this industry
i don't need to worry because i i just
followed the formula
yep i'm off the hook and that's why
people
ask me for tactics all the time and why
i don't give them tactics
because we don't need the next scott
alexander we already have one
two would be good though it might keep
it might keep the uh the human race
going a little bit more
um what does be paranoid about
mediocrity me
so perfectionism and mediocrity
are both the same thing and what they
are
are places to hide perfectionism means i
will never be finished
because how could it be perfect and
perfectionism
feels like a worthwhile endeavor because
we say what do you want me to just ship
junk and so we hide behind perfectionism
mediocrity the flip side of that is well
what the hell i just put it out there
can't hold me responsible i didn't
really work very hard at it
again i'm off the hook so medioc
mediocre is another word for average and
most organizations make average stuff
most creators make average stuff for
average people that's what makes it
average
most and if your
average stuff doesn't happen no one will
miss it because there's plenty of
average stuff to take its place
but if you can figure out how to do
something that's beyond mediocre
not perfect but simply changing the
situation
solving the interesting problem that we
would miss
if it weren't here but there's all this
pressure on you to make it average
and the easier way to deal with that
pressure is to say
let's call it mediocre instead
i'm going to guess that again this all
of these threads tie together
if you are pushing the work rate
of the work that you do there also has
to be a point at which you accept
it is good enough if you need to release
a blog post every day
and you work on it until tomorrow it's
tomorrow like you have to press the
publish button at some point
correct so you just use the two-word
phrase that i really like
which is good enough so let's be really
honest about what good enough means
we defined good enough in advance to
mean
it's good enough anything better than
good enough
either we've made a mistake in our
definition or we've wasted time and
money
right so when they made the lexus
to compete with mercedes good enough
meant it has to be higher quality than
any mercedes ever built
but it didn't have to be perfect it
didn't have to be a car that would go 2
million miles on a gallon of gas
right it just had to be better than the
best mercedes
that was their definition of good enough
and then you ship it
and so if you're having trouble defining
good enough go
work on that but once you define what
good enough is
that's spec and the definition of
quality is meeting spec
so instead of good enough we just call
it quality but they're the same thing
meet spec that liberates you to increase
this work rate
as well as we said before which makes
you able to learn more
because work that doesn't ship doesn't
count
and one of the reasons it doesn't count
is it can't fail if it can't fail you
don't learn anything
there's a twitter account run by my good
friend jack butcher from visualize value
called
advice inverted and
the top pinned post at the moment is
intentions matter more than actions
there you go i love that that
there's a lot of layers there that's
great he's a smart
smart smart fella uh talking of actions
one of the things upon reading james
clear's atomic abits last year
um was this kind of identity-based
change that i've really realized
um and you say that we become
what we do um which is an interesting
uh how do you say symbiotic relationship
between we have a inclination
we feed it it gives us something back
it becomes this kind of self-sustaining
process
and before you know it you've become the
work the work is you
you know i mean it kind of this it
starts well done it's not just the work
i mean a lot of people are waiting to
become an honest person and then they'll
go tell the truth
well but if you want to be an honest
person start by telling the truth
if you want to be a runner you don't
need a permit you just need to run
30 days in a row then you're a runner if
you want to be a writer
just write 30 days in a row then you're
a writer do the work
and then you can get the mantle then you
become the thing
that the work represents
is there something is there a single
thread that you see
amongst creative people uh a unifying
characteristic which is most prominent
in them
it tends to um have two poles
and they might be related i just haven't
found it yet
one of them is the
ego strength of the i
and i made this i and i alone solved
this problem i
showed up you know this is the symphony
conductor who
cannot be replaced uh the other one
is the restlessness of
seeing defects in the world that
interesting problems beg to be solved
no credit necessary i just need this
problem to be solved
uh i can do both not usually at the same
time but i've
felt both inclination so you know if i'm
at a uh
back in the old days when i was in a
restaurant i'm sitting at a restaurant
and the door
keeps slamming because the spring was
disconnected
and there's you know 30 people in the
restaurant and everyone's annoyed by
this
so i just got up and put the spring back
on because i just couldn't sit there
knowing
that all it needed was the spring to be
hooked up and i didn't wait for the
manager to tell me it was okay
the manager wanted the spring to be off
they could take the spring off later
that instinct is something we see in
creative people
all the time it often happens when we're
seeing
organizations do creative work on the
other hand there's
definitely thanks to the media the
impresario
you know nikola tesla henry ford thing
of
i and i alone invented the future
and a lot of times we benefit from that
and sometimes megalomaniacs
pay a big price or we all pay a big
price for pigelo maniacs
yeah when we look at those people from
the outside
i think everyone loves the idea of being
elon musk but no one really knows what
it's like inside of his head when he
goes to bed at night this is a big
a big insight from naval ravikant and
tim ferriss about i cannot take part of
someone's life
i have to take the whole like do you
want to pay the price the whole
sale not piecemeal ship it in bulk
one unit do not assemble at home elon
musk
internal monologue price because that's
well said that's the price
that you would have to pay um i have one
one question that i really want to ask
you which i'm going to finish on but
before that um
which company is doing some of your
favorite marketing right now is there
anything you've seen in 2020 that you've
been particularly impressed or
happy with my answer is
any company that someone can name
that they feel like they have a
relationship with that they feel like
is doing something that works for them
is on my list
it's not necessarily the one i would
pick but the fact that someone feels
that way
is proof that they're on to something so
you know there were brands 20 30 40
years ago that had that relationship
with people and now they're just turning
it up
and then there are other brands that
didn't used to mean very much
but now they do and that's the symptom
that somebody there found the smallest
viable audience and decided
to do creative work i have found that
anytime i
write about a company the owner gets
into enormous amounts of
trouble for bad behavior or something
and so i don't do that anymore
that's a that's a fair point yeah i
understand do you think it's possible
for companies to scale up to the
sort of hyper structure like
the sphere in the in the upper ethanol
of the
of the atmosphere and retain that level
of
creativity well okay so there's
different kinds of companies in
different kinds of scale
without a doubt uh there have been
entire decades
in which places like hollywood using a
studio model
produced endless amounts of
extraordinary creativity
that um you know 1939 in the movie
business
was just stunning it was a lot of people
working but they were
parallel it wasn't a hierarchy
then there's you know apple at its prime
which is pre-tim cook and there you had
a
really rigid hierarchy with a lot of
leverage
and so they didn't come out with that
many different products but the products
they came out with
you know paved the earth they just
changed everything
and it's interesting to see that as soon
as tim came in his goal was to make the
stock price go up
and so his sole innovation at apple
has been making them the most valuable
company in the world as opposed to
changing our culture in ways that you
could point to and say
wow that was creative is there a
corner going to come at some point in
future where we move away
from these socialized metrics of success
and
embrace internal measures of success
yeah i mean i don't know if i'm still
going to be around when ai
has uh not just replaced all the
assembly line workers and the travel
agents but people like you and me
in terms of doing the work that people
pay for
but as we create
more and more value we have to decide is
it going to get into
the hands of fewer or fewer people or
are we going to treat so many of the
things we pay for now
as rights the way we think of
roads or clean water or library cards
because we can afford it and if that
happens the question is where will our
status roles come from
where will our social hierarchies come
from because they're not going to be
who made more money and sorry
it's going to be i think the key is then
to say
is the purpose of our culture to enable
capitalism
or is the purpose of capitalism to
enable culture
and i would like to believe it's the
latter and to get there
i think we end up with a world a lot
more like the amateur
blogosphere podcast sphere and a lot
less
like how do i sell more whatever on the
street corner by hustling out the other
guy
yeah i hope so so my final question what
insight about life do you wish more
people knew
i think that uh we have more leverage
than we thought
and you don't have to change everything
but you can change something
and if enough people make a change for
the better and stop acting like victims
even though many of us are victims who
got the short end of the stick
we can make things better and that's not
the right answer to every question we
need organized government we need
coordinated action to undo
indoctrination and
injustice and so many other things but
that doesn't mean we should wait till
that happens
we got to start right this minute and
make things better
i love it sir thank you so much for
coming on the practice shipping creative
work
will be linked in the show notes below
of course if people want to check out
anything else where should they go
i started an organization i don't run
anymore called the kimbo where we run
workshops including the alt mba
it's at akimbo.com and my blog every day
as long as i have anything to do with it
is it seth blog
amazing everything's linked in the show
notes below i've absolutely adored this
thankfully now that you're on my list
you are releasing was it 19 books 18
books deep that you are now something
like that
this 20 20th bestseller today's the day
congratulations man thank you
congratulations uh
that means basically i have probably two
episodes a year less that i need to
schedule in
because i can just continue to hassle
your guys seth's brought a new book out
thank you yeah i'll take him 6 p.m on
tuesday
catch you later on um everyone that's
been listening any questions comments
you know what to do leave them in the
comments below
but for now seth thank you so much
thanks chris keep making a ruckus this
was fun
you